[Applause]
i just love what you guys are putting
out there
into the world it is so real and honest
and you're right
comedy to me is medicine and you said
you know have you you dated
a a comedian that's all i ever wanted
like if you can
you know now i care about kind um but
before it was just funny and
i still want funny i want kind and funny
but
funny it's true and i love that you said
you see the world
in different shapes that's what comedy
does it's like we're putting on
different skin and a different like
brain and inserting a different heart
that
isn't our own because there's so much
comedy that stuff we don't feel like we
can touch
or do or say so we need someone else to
do
and say it this the world is very
sensitive
right now comedy is not like it used to
be but go ahead uh
sherry drew i don't know if you're like
kim and i when you have a zoo meeting
with the teacher and they come on and
you're like what
yeah like you're just you're immediately
defensive but
like in the case of kim joshua is
younger than jeffrey he's a little bit
more independent joshua is nine years
old
and so we'll be we'll be shooting the
podcast
or having a business meeting and
literally we're talking
and kim will be like joshua just do it
i mean just try turn off that you stop
twirling around in your chair joshua
do your math okay and she will literally
leave
the the zoom meeting to go
and help joshua and i'll be there by
myself if kim stays on this zoom
with you drew i will be surprised cause
she just walks away
and deals with herself it's bad it's bad
imagine all the people with younger
children
you can't control them they don't care
who you are in life
they need some things done and they want
their mommy we have been
in this pandemic for a while now no
sherry i'm telling you it's gotten so
bad like you said
i was so tired of mommy mommy i changed
my name to homework
[Laughter]
parenting is not perfect parenting is
like you know how you go to the outlet
store and you found
and you find that imperfect pair of
jeans it got all kind of things little
wrong with it
but you love them that's what children
love you there's some problems but they
love you
and you got to make those little
mistakes it's okay even if
jeans have no crotch you sow something
imperfect you have to learn to embrace
the chaos it's okay
jeffrey was on his computer and i forgot
that boy he because he's supposed to be
in school
i forgot he was there i walked right
through the computer naked his
got a little glimpse of his mama you
know what it's okay
stuff happens i walked past one time
without my hair they thought it was his
father
not your hair you forgot to put your
hair on
girl it's too early when they start
those classes you forget
it's so true i have had so many
incidents on zoom
that you know one time my kid and i got
into it and then i walked into the room
and this tutor was on the zoom like
yes and i was like oh great now you
think i'm a bad mom because my kid and i
got into it you know what we needed to
we needed to let the air out of this
pressure and that's the only context you
have
good now oh what you have to do you have
to scream like that
because i screamed like that the other
day with kim i was like i'm going
through
two birthdays in the pandemic i got
these big lips
i need to kiss somebody
i love you hello can i give can i give a
shout out of my new movie coming out
real quick
yes please give the shout out right now
i want to give the shout out to hubie
halloween with adam sandlers who is the
best
in the world it comes out on october
that guy i do and i love hubie halloween
and i think it's destined to be an
absolute classic because there aren't
comedies on halloween
all the time and this is a totally
unique movie and such a pleasure and i
i can't wait to talk about it when it's
coming out and we'll be celebrating
that and i lost 28 pounds on ww weight
watchers that's all just what to say
by the way i know when everybody was
putting the weight on
you lost i did look at that
it is this app they got this ww weight
watchers has an app
that helps and i didn't believe that it
was going to work
and i have lost this weight and living a
healthy
lifestyle and having fun with it and i
get to eat real food and
it's not hard i i didn't think i could
do it i'll be honest with you
that underneath sherry is my biggest
cheerleader because i've had to work to
find the balance too and so that's why
i've always been ears open
about that ww program because people are
just wild
for it they say it really works it
really works it's a science i don't know
how but
drew if you need any kind of help with
wwe i am there for you they got coaches
they
the app is like a little genie in my
pocket i'm telling you i open up this
app i put my food in it i say what i
want
and i put my little points in it i lose
weight i got recipes
i get to feed my kids with the same food
okay i'm sorry
and sherry's on dish nation every day
i'm sorry i had i
had to get mine out i love it you guys
thank you
come here talk plug let's do this thank
you guys so much for being here
thank you thank you thank you thank you
two funny mamas
sherry and kim